the emoji movie a works so completely
devoid of wit style intelligence or
basic entertainment value that it makes
that movie based on the Angry Birds app
seem like a pure artistic statement by
comparison roger ebert calm the emoji
movie is so bad it makes us want to yell
at strangers on the street I don't think
I can say anything funny about this
because it makes me want to die The
Verge make no mistake the emoji movie is
very very very bad indie wire so bad it
should be illegal oh wait it actually is
illegal that quotes from me and I'm
gonna prove to you why today
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory a
show best represented by the sad clown
emoji you see he's sad because he lost
custody of his kids that's the way the
show makes you feel like a lonely lonely
crying clown speaking of things that'll
make you depressed vo OG movie the worst
reviewed movie of 2017 and xxx the most
successful movie of 2017 at the box
office this year raking in over 85
million dollars so far you can make it
rain emoji just goes to show you that if
you talk about something enough it just
grows stronger
is there a Trump emoji that I could show
here seems pertinent anyway there's no
denying that this tale of an emoji who
just can't quite fit in plus a bad movie
lame lazy formulaic that much is clear
but the question I'm posing to you today
is whether the emoji movie should have
been deemed illegal another click
baiting you or anything I am
legitimately asking the question of
whether the emoji movie breaks legal
requirements put in place by the
government to protect viewers from the
evil scourge that savagely de flowering
the good ol USA sponsored content or to
use the official term embedded
advertising now obviously over my six
years of being on YouTube I have done my
fair share of sponsored videos be it an
end slate promoting a product like
Dollar Shave Club or a full-on episode
dedicated to a theory I've crafted for a
specific movie TV show or game leaked
the recent duck tails episode over here
on film theory and here's the thing
sponsorships are essential for helping
to supplement the income of channels and
for me it ensures that I'm able to help
pay the team of researchers and editors
who help me produce game theory and film
Theory every week since at this point
that's what YouTube demands for channels
to stay relevant but regardless in the
process of doing those promotional
segments I've had to become intimately
familiar with the proper way of
disclosing different styles of branded
partnerships because there are very
strict guidelines for how you make an
audience aware that those are ads you
see in the US we have the Federal Trade
Commission or FTC and the Federal
Communications Commission or FCC who
come up with the rules that anyone who
produces a piece of content has to
follow in order to ensure that the
audience is able to tell that the brand
paid to be there it doesn't even have to
be payment even if they provided free
goods or it's some other consideration
like cross-promotion is still got to
make the audience aware of that sort of
thing the underlying rationale here is
that if I sip it Diet Coke and say man
that is a crisp clean taste but Diet
Coke paid for that placement I might
just be saying it because they told me
to but if I say it and promote it across
six years worth of videos and they
didn't pay for any of that well you can
just assume that I'm an addict because I
am meatus closing that they partnered
with me before the ad run allows you as
the audience to be a bit more critical
of the promotion and there are
government protections in place to
ensure that you as the viewer aren't
being tricked or misled but then I went
to see the emoji movie and let me be
clear it was for research purposes only
and I probably watched puppies playing
with kittens to serve as I bleach
afterwards and watching the movie I
couldn't help but be dumbfounded by the
number of blatant product integrations
that were happening without any sort of
disclosure things that were I to do them
would immediately get my video flagged
and fined by the FTC prompting a s'more
of angry judge emoji followed by years
of jail time emoji and tons of money
flying away emoji so today I'm analyzing
the product integrations in the movie to
prove that they're actually breaking FTC
and FCC requirements to determine
whether the movie that's so bad it's bad
is also bad from a legal standpoint -
anytime you see a brand appear anywhere
like how everyone in twilight
mysteriously drives full bows or how
James Bond abandoned his trip comes to
martinis in exchange for a bright green
Heineken bottle it falls under the
classification of embedded advertising
the term embedded advertising basically
covers two things product placements and
product integrations in product
placement the product pays a fee or
offers some other consideration and gets
their brand logo or product into the
movie their product then basically
becomes a prop like Reese's Pieces and
et or those seamlessly integrated Dunkin
Donuts cups on America's Got Talent
or literally once every 10 frames in any
Transformers movie its bet to seem like
an accident like oh look these things
exist in the real world and they just so
happen to show up in the scene you like
music
the pool but of course it's not an
accident
in fact Rhys is paid for each of those
pieces spending 1 million dollars to
help promote the movie to be included in
that iconic scene from ET so that's
option 1 product placement option 2 is
product integration where the brand is
actively incorporated into the story or
dialog take for instance one of my
favorite examples
Snapple appearing in 30 rock where they
talk directly about the benefits of
Snapple
we're not doing that we're not
compromising the integrity of the show
to say oh this is Diet Snapple
I only date guys who drink Snapple your
love Snapple lord knows I do or Little
Nicky using popeyes chicken to save the
earth from demons or in this iconic
moment that's close to a lot of our
hearts I love the power glove it's so
big and again if the brand doesn't pay
to be there it doesn't count like me
saying how much I still love drinking
diet coke lonely unspun surd rejected by
the sweet sweet Cola company of my
dreams Diet Coke so now we turn back to
the emoji movie and one of the biggest
most glaring examples of embedded
advertising in the film
everyone's grandma's favorite mobile
game candy crush let's look at the scene
a little bit closer to see what the FTC
and FCC have to say about whether this
merits a sponsorship disclosure at the
beginning you can clearly see the candy
crush logo which means we've already
definitely crossed into product
placement territory but then the movie
directly says the name of the app candy
droid and the characters directly talk
about the functionality of the game and
we can't match him with any yellows or
else then after that the emoji character
literally has to win the game to forward
the plot of the movie this clearly falls
under category two product integration
we also know that none of this was an
accident
king the company who owns candy crush
very publicly teamed up with the emoji
movie to do one of the biggest cross
promotions in the game's history even
creating special emoji movie levels in
the game to promote the film
what does the FTC guidelines have to say
about integrations like this first you
need to disclose everything up front to
quote directly from the FTC guidelines
an endorsement would be covered by the
FTC act if an advertiser or someone
working for an advertiser pays you or
gives you something of value to mention
a product if you receive free products
or other perks with the expectation that
you'll promote or discuss the
advertisers products you must disclose
this is literally on the front page of
the FTC disclosure site so how did the
emoji movie miss this remember it
doesn't even say they have to like the
product if it appears if you mention it
it counts and needs disclosure but who
knows maybe they did disclose maybe they
did it in the movie credits those things
go on forever so it must be in there
somewhere right right oh look there it
is in that giant block of text five
minutes into the credits but that's not
gonna cut it in the eyes of the FTC they
emphasize over and over again in their
rules and FAQ that disclosures need to
be clear hard to miss and accurately
represent the relationship between the
video and the brand it has to be quote
in unambiguous language and whoever
makes the video has to make it stand out
the fun has to be readable it has to
stand out from the background and it
shouldn't be hidden in footnotes or
blocks of text or put in places people
aren't likely to read save for instance
the closing credits of a movie they even
explicitly say to avoid the end of a
piece of content again another quote
from FTC guidelines quote it's more
likely that a disclosure at the end of a
video will be missed especially if
someone doesn't watch the whole thing
having it at the beginning would be
better
having multiple disclosures during the
video would be even better
nope sorry FTC you just get a handful of
courtesy by mixed into a wall of text an
hour after that embedded advertising
happened and remember that hole
accurately represent the relationship
between video and brand bit Apple
something tells me that the relationship
between King and Sony Pictures looked a
whole lot different than the
relationship between Rosanna pansino and
Sony Pictures but all of it apparently
is the same courtesy of that doesn't
even imply that any sort of payment or
promotional consideration changed hands
but we all know it did so that is not an
accurate descriptor based on the FTC
guidelines and I have to tell you that's
just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to integrations in this movie the
entire movie is hopping from one
invented ad to the next Twitter to
YouTube to Spotify to Instagram to
Facebook millions of moviegoers were
literally tricked into paying money to
watch an hour and 31 minutes of
commercials you guys I wish I were
joking and the exact same disclosure
rule should apply to each of those but
especially the other two biggest product
integrations in this movie Dropbox and
just dance and if you thought candy
crush was bad these two are even worse
in the scene for just dance now it's not
just that the characters are just
dancing they're actually endorsing the
product they start by literally
explaining the rules of the game follow
my move you get an X then sell the
product as an app made for everyone come
on everybody can dance then they make
positive comments about using the app
for the rest of this excruciating ly
long seed oh really
you love it just language like that
matter to the FTC oh you bet it does
there's a line of the FTC guidelines
specifically about implicit endorsements
of products here it is simply posting a
picture of a product or a video of you
using it could convey that you like and
approve of the product if it does it's
an endorsement you don't necessarily
have to use words to convey a positive
message yeah you could do things like
smile use nonverbal sounds like whoa or
show that you can use the product well
if you do any one of those things the
FTC is expecting you to be doing some
disclosing it's even more blatant for
Dropbox and let's be honest here Dropbox
I can just see six-year-old Timmy
sitting there in the theater being like
oh thank goodness there's finally a
secure solution for my file transfer
needs then he digs a booger out of his
nose and uses it to garnish his snow cap
but for Dropbox in this movie it's
really bad literally they stand in awe
of Dropbox's magnificent firewall then
they demonstrate the password
for the app and how strong its security
is then of course they make it
explicitly clear that the evil malware
emoji can't get through because you know
it's malware and malware can't get into
the great secure app of Dropbox this is
not just product integration this is a
direct demonstration and endorsement
basically the pinnacle of all that is
hashtag spawned so long story short
screw the legal mumbo jumbo the results
are definitively clear the emoji movie
is totally out of line look no further
than the FTC guidelines it violates
rules that myself and literally millions
of other youtubers are held to every day
shut it down everyone call in the feds
let them know that these violators
should receive as many frowny face emoji
as they've got down there at the FTC not
only is this movie a huge steaming poop
emoji but it's also a poop emoji behind
bars emoji because what they are doing
is literally illegal you will profane
the emoji movie no longer
his dad's too strong yet good later the
emoji Moody's ability to make young
impressionable minds aware of quality
malware free file-sharing services like
Dropbox and the endless hours have fun
they can derive from the incredible just
dance that with its selection of 283 of
today's hottest dance tunes is protected
by section three one seven of the FCC's
Communications Act which states that any
motion picture film produced through
appear in theaters doesn't have to
disclose its brand partnerships curse
you Jack's films and your robust
knowledge of arcane legalese but
seriously is that really true would the
emoji movie lie I mean have you ever had
this much fun playing just dance now yes
Jack's films away I didn't make up all
those other disclosure rules though
those are all on the FTC and FCC
guidelines so if movies are exempt from
having to disclose that they're getting
paid millions of dollars from these
products for some reason then what these
rules only apply to TV newspapers in
digital video just digital TV is judged
by other standards as long as that
Milton Bradley promotion is listed off
in the closing credits of that episode
of Big Bang Theory y'all good family why
is the audience laughing at this they're
just playing twister they're not even in
funny positions because it's hilarious
Matt oh boy between this and the emoji
movie this year has been a comedic
powerhouse but no one even shows the
credits of TV programs anymore at best
they're off in a tiny corner while the
next show starts playing yep and
meanwhile youtubers and other digital
video creators have to disclose an ad at
the opening seconds of the video and
then again when the actual integration
starts so viewers don't miss it yeah and
and movies don't have to do any of this
you betcha why let's be honest people
were probably paid off absolute the fact
that money rarely directly changes hands
even said it yourself to get Reese's
Pieces into et Hershey's spent 1 million
dollars promoting the movie movies found
a loophole they also cite their First
Amendment rights to disclose at the
beginning
in the middle of the movie would take
away their rights to tell the artistic
story they want to tell I don't know
with James Bond is willing to switch
from his iconic martinis to a bargain
beer for forty five million dollars
something tells me that arts and free
speech may not be the driving factors in
that creative decision who's speaking of
bidding I hope in the emoji movie too
they go to the eBay app what I wouldn't
do to see gene getting a bidding war
with jailbreak boy what I jinx so what
you're telling me is that if the emoji
movie were a YouTube video or a movie
made for Facebook or whatever it would
be illegal because it doesn't disclose
the brand endorsements but because it's
a feature film in theaters it's
perfectly fine yeah even if it's
directly targeting children yep
doesn't it seem hypocritical and unfair
that laws require youtubers to disclose
brand deals multiple times to make sure
the audience knows the relationship
between the brand and the creative while
films get tens of millions of dollars
have emoji learn how to play candy crush
and the efforts of getting kids to play
the game and none of it has to be
disclosed anywhere it does and that's
what makes the brilliant creative minds
of Sony Pictures animation so brilliant
and creative but my work here is done
Jack's films away the FTC guidelines
covering online bloggers and things like
YouTube videos is over 10,000 words long
that is longer than the entire script of
the emoji movie which clocks in at 7426
words oh yeah I counted the expectations
for disclosures and movies are covered
in 30 words but can be summarized in
four you don't need to and let me make
it clear I'm not opposed to disclosure I
think it's important but I think it
needs to be fair for movies for
television and for bloggers I'm gonna
quote now from question one of the FTC
guidelines do the endorsement guides
apply to social media fair response yes
truth and advertising is important in
all media whether they have been around
for decades like television and
magazines or a relatively new like blogs
and social media
notice the form of media whose
conspicuously absent their movies the
FTC states that the goals of these
regulations are to help consumers
distinguish ads from content but perhaps
the worst part of all of this is that
the emoji movie is clearly tarred
kids who according to studies by the
association for consumer research don't
even understand that commercials exist
to sell a product if these government
agencies are truly invested in
protecting viewers they should spend a
little less time spending out notices to
instagramers and spend a bit more time
asking these 90-minute commercials to
shape up kpop wait no that's an app to
hash tag not spawn hash tag not spawn
and probably never spawned again prepare
for a lot more YouTube theories my
friends but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and the special thanks to
Jax filled the emoji movies quote
unquote biggest fan for helping me out
with today's episode if you missed his
hilarious review of the movie then BAM
there's the link on screen right now
just uh Jack makes sure to slap a
hashtag spawn on that poop emoji chest
area have at the end and on a more
serious note please help support
independent creators like Jax films and
us here at film theory who are trying to
do good work in a system that's
obviously rigged against us how can you
do that you ask well there are a lot of
ways but the easiest answer is by
subscribing and then watching our videos
links around screen now so please find
it in your heart to click them now if
you'll excuse me I need to go hide I was
already on some government watch lists
before but calling out unfair
relationships between the government and
the entertainment industry I'm sure is
making me no friends so fingers crossed
all of our videos don't get flagged